[موسيقى]
هم لا يعرفون انهم مختلفون نحن من نخلق
الاختلاف ونشعرهم به كسر ادركوا هذه
الحقيقه ومنهم ناهد الام التي تريد الذهاب
بهم الى اقصى ما لديهم ان تكتشف مهاراتهم
في فضاء يجمعهم حيث لا اختلاف ولا تنمر
اعطت فكره ماي ماكس من احمد ولله الحمد
انا ناهده الام قبل اي شيء بنات كل هذا
المكان وانا بحلم في مكان لاحمد اشوف احمد
فيهم اشوف احمد عنده حياه وكانت احلامي
كاي ام كبيره جدا للاسف بعد ما بنيت
المكان هذا احمد احتياجاته مختلفه واصبح
احمد اليوم ما موجود في هذا المكان لكن
اصبح المكان لكل الاحمدات الموجودين في
هذه الحياه اصبح عندي اكثر من احمد اصبح
عندي علي اصبح عندي خالد بنادوني يا امي
وابني انا ما بتكلم بعد رحلتي مع احمد
الطويله احمد هو احمد هل تغيرت انا مش
فحبيت انا انه اغير احمد احمد ما بتغير
[موسيقى]
احمد الداني قوه مضاعفه فان اكون انا
الشخص الان اللي يقدر يساعد كل هذول الناس
وحتى ما شايفه انه انا قويه
ما شايفه هذا الشيء فهل في قوه اكثر من
كذا هذا قوه احمد المصنف معاق المعاق غير
ضعيف المعاق شخص من حقه ان يعيش كل انسان
فينا عنده اعاقته الخاصه المسميات لا تعني
شيء